living in his mom's basement I Never
Said So what I just read the Super Chat
someone said so what I don't know who Oh
no you're hearing things maybe it's time
for bed you were looking for trouble
King Richard you're not that blood I
don't care
it's his show you're not saying I don't
care anyway
um where are we at all right we got
Trent Rollins he's back again uh black
women want the guy raised on Survival
not love a sophisticated hood dude an
anomaly oh I'd love a sophisticated
hoodlum but raised on love not survival
yes yeah but if a guy if a guy is on
this Drilling and trapping scamming all
of that kind of stuff yeah it is
survival though he's on survival mode
but how will he be willing how will he
know how to love me if he doesn't know
like if he hasn't that's what you should
ask yourself when you start dating them
there you go like if you mean there you
go that's what you should ask yourself
when you date them I don't I make it
excuse me
because she said she picked
I've got
Five
Guys
there you go I'm not saying not to do
that I'm just saying ask yourself
depressed and miserable actually could
be do not say that again the nine to
five maybe
not that one the other one
what did you say I said I bought nine to
five and that was the most miserable
time of my life because a lot of the
time you're working for peanuts for
somebody that is making millions of your
bag you're going you not only you know
you're nine to five which means you need
to get there even probably half a lot a
lot of time you may have to commute wear
stiff as clothes you have one hour break
in a whole eight hour day like ugh I
don't agree with that go on um
[Music]
if I started to work at McDonald's
earning five pounds an hour when I was
18 when I came to this country and now
I'm living my best life due to my nine
to five come on so I feel like it
depends on the situation I've been to
jobs that yeah I was a slave but I feel
like you work your way up
and so and you know and and and you know
why that's so
why that's so mad that she said that
because she's the white girl here
what are you trying to say
well it's quite it's kind of obvious
what I'm trying to say is that she's
kind of obviously say it in words
huh are you trying to say that she's
more stable because she's what no say
okay let me let me make it let me put my
phone down yeah basically yeah basically
so we're talking about nine to fives
versus uh bad criminals fast money
whatever yeah and basically you said
you'd pick a scammer over nine to five
then you were talking about how bad the
nine to five is the lady in the middle
didn't really say nothing but we already
know that she's been with the gangster
boys and then the lady on the end said
you know what I I don't agree I made my
way through working hard being a slave
yeah came came to the country 18
McDonald's worked your way out now
you're living your best life and that's
respectable do you get insane that's not
saying that's not downgrading what you
do for a living but that is just stating
the the facts and that stating some of
the things that black guys say about why
they day out because there's a mentality
amongst us you know no bruv there's a
mentality in our community that we all
know but maybe she loves what she does
for nine to five some people don't love
what they do in some some imagination
stuff let's go with an imagination of
what she said go off what she said
Cameron she's a woman I sent you a video
the other day about guys about Brooke
guys right you make less money on a nine
to five than you do if you're out there
doing it more flexible I like one of
these other brothers the more flexible
job working for yourself I'd rather be
an entrepreneur than to be working I'm
not trying to a point in my life I don't
understand why for real I don't
understand why black people think nine
to fives aren't about making money every
person I know that works nine to five
make it 300 000 pounds a year like I
like I don't understand that is that in
finance well in the U.S too so we get
you know yeah um and then and then also
man damn I forgot what the hell I was
gonna say sorry at the end of the day
they're tapped bro
it's tapped one more thing I don't like
in the black community we have this oh
we don't like what we do
oh we need to find listen though the
white folks and the Asian folks I know
and and me I was getting destroyed I was
sleeping on a mat on the floor at
Harvard getting destroyed okay in order
to get that back to be able to finish my
training next year and and make 40 hours
a week every weekend off get home at 5
PM 300 000 pounds a year okay you have
to work hard and it's not going to be
fun and you like it's gonna be fun it's
not gonna be fun I'm not talking about
working hard I'm talking about the
monotonous routine
yeah
no no no no no one wish yeah let me tell
you oh I read a book by 50 Cent yeah
he's the the baddest bad boy in the
Philippine rap that you can think of
power all of these kind of things yeah
you would look at him as an entrepreneur
would you not yes yeah guess what he
said in his book hustle harder yeah
monotonous repetition Ralph is the key
to success monotonous repetition when
you're working for yourself now when
you're working for another person
you didn't read the book and you're
asking yeah but I mean yeah but you did
not read the book and you're adding in
your own interpretation but I'm telling
you what was written down bro but you're
basically I'm mad bro yes it's actually
mad it's not making money it's not about
your actual happiness I'm I told I
worked like and that's why I said
miserable I didn't say broke
right let me just say something like you
see this listen what you see this whole
discussion here this is showing how men
think logically forward yes and women
think emotionally forward and
are necessarily right or wrong because
it's always tailored to your situation
no no no but I'll tell you why because I
I believe when you've got to work hard
before you work smart you can't just
jump into it so yeah that means you're
gonna have to go through the nine to
fives and the daily routines and
sacrifice and maybe you're not gonna
have a certain amount at the end of this
month for you're not gonna but if you're
self-investing and you're doing certain
things with in order to get what you
need what you want or where you need to
be that's where you can start
accumulating yeah I'm not saying that
you should be a wage slave your whole
life and just yeah be in a rat race your
whole life but I'm saying do not talk
down on this whole nine to five thing
because guess what most of our parents
did it
and most people on this planet do it so
again it goes back to that thinking of
this top 10 of people out there and what
they're doing and yeah you've got to be
like them bro like at the end of the day
most people are not gonna ever reach
that because it's not feasible for
everyone to be bowling yeah it's not
brown so when you talk when you talk
negative about all of this nine to five
it's actually ridiculous because most
most people are gonna have to do it yeah
hey but this is
listen my name is King riches remember
that yes
say it properly all right we're gonna
keep going with the super chats blood
you can't say King Richard's probably
about as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible